[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à quelques pas de
l'intersection où la jeune Ukrainienne
Maria a été tué en décembre et d'emblée
Valérie plante résume son constat il y a
trop
les quartiers résidantiels c'est des
milliers de vie puis c'est pas des
raccourcis là où l'accident a eu lieu
une rue Nord-Sud descend vers le
centre-ville c'est une rue en pente qui
a une forte pente donc ça veut dire que
les automobilistes prennent très
facilement de la vitesse le 30 km/h je
suis sûr qu'il n'y ait jamais
qui n'est jamais respecté le stop n'est
pas non plus respecté elle se réjouit de
l'annonce du jour qui consiste à rendre
la traversée du quartier plus compliqué
à la prochaine rentrée scolaire la rue
folom sera en sens unique vers le nord
et on inversera le sens d'une portion de
deux autres rues ce qu'on veut mettre en
priorité c'est la sécurité des gens et
non plus la fluidité est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à plus de labyrinthe comme
sur le plateau je vais pas compliquer la
vie des automobilistes mais moi ce que
je veux c'est protéger des vies
l'initiative devrait porter ses fruits
selon ce spécialiste des transports
apolitechnique mais on peut aller encore
plus loin c'est la seule façon
c'est bien de décourager physiquement on
va le dire de d'empêcher de gêner de
ralentir le passage sur ces rues là et
ça passe par ce type de mesures entre
autres tout le monde a cité Paris par
exemple récemment qui a vraiment un
programme assez large ou que ce soit des
rues devant les écoles si complètement
fermées à la circulation automobile ou
qui sont fermées aux heures de dépôt des
enfants les résidents du secteur eux
comptent sur d'autres actions des radars
qui sont installés dans les zones
scolaires mais c'est une décision qui
relève de Québec l'annonce du jour
portait sur un secteur la ville a promis
dans sécuriser 50 en 2023 au coup de 10
millions de dollars ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal